today we're talking about gartner
results cloud logging unattended
projects and private service connect i'm
stephanie wong and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
for the fourth consecutive year gartner
has positioned google as a leader in the
2021 gartner magic quadrant for cloud
infrastructure and platform services our
enterprise ready cloud provides you the
uptime performance and scale to run even
your most demanding workloads and not to
mention it saves you money and has
unmatched security so check out the blog
for more
to help you offload operational tasks
associated with running your own logging
stack we offer cloud logging if you
don't need to worry about data residency
cloud logging will pick a region for you
but if you do have data governance or
compliance requirements we're excited to
share that cloud logging now offers more
flexibility and control by providing you
a choice of 23 regions to store and
process your logging data
things get busy and it's not uncommon to
forget about one of the many things
you've got going on including full
projects to help you prune your idle
cloud resources we're excited to
introduce unattended project recommender
it's a new ml driven feature of active
assist that provides you with a one-stop
shop for discovering reclaiming and
shutting down unattended projects check
it out in the recommender api today
private service connect is now in ga and
allows you to consume services quickly
privately and securely with private
service connect you can create private
and secure connections from your cloud
networks to services like cloud storage
or bigtable and third-party services
like elastic mongodb or snowflake it
creates service endpoints in your vpcs
that provide private connectivity and
policy enforcement allowing you to
easily connect services across different
networks and organizations
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud